[Musique]
en surface on ne voit rien à part les
installations de surface par contre en
sous sol le gaz est stocké dans un roche
poreuse qui représente 1 milliard 500
millions de mètres cubes de gaz
est l'équivalent de 600 milles piscine
olympique
[Musique]
donc voir regarder
pendant les pointes de froid nous sommes
capables de mettre à disposition du
réseau des consommateurs une puissance
instantanée allant jusqu'à 75 gigawatts
[Musique]
la chance de la france c'est qu'elle a
un approvisionnement qui est diversifié
avec différentes sources différents pays
producteurs de gaz qui alimente la
france à la fois au niveau terrestre
mais aussi et de plus en plus cette
année au niveau maritime en termes de
gaz naturel liquéfié
[Musique]
on
oui
[Musique]